Strangely enough,...
...winning millions in the lottery can be the worst thing that ever happened to you.
The money can strain relationships with your spouse and relatives.
It can turn your friends and neighbors into leeches.
It can ruin your privacy.
It can cause security problems and threaten your physical safety.
Paradoxically, it can lead you down the road to bankruptcy.
So if you win a multi - million dollar prize,...
...don't tell anyone or sign ticket. Act casual.
Copy ticket and put in a safe deposit box.
Contact a tax attorney and financial planner.
Open a blind trust to maintain privacy.
Tie up any financial loose ends.
Draft or update your will.
Move to a house with security guards.
Last, wait a little longer - tell spouse last.
Cheated by the Lottery.
A redneck buys a lottery ticket and wins.
He goes to claim it and his ticket number is verified.
He says, "Give me my two billion won."
The lottery representative replied, "Sorry, sir.
We'll give you a hundred million won today...
...and then you'll get the rest spread out for the next 19 years."
The redneck said, "Oh, no. I want it all now!"
Again, the man explains how the payment works.
The furious redneck screams out, "Look! I want my money!...
...If you're not going to give me my two billion won right now,...
...then I want my thousand won bill back."